avez vous des regrets aujourd'hui alors
toutes ces questions métaphysiques
on se les idées touche pause et on se
déposera tous généralement vers 40 ans
alors pourquoi s'est posée bas parce que
la vie est ainsi faite
l'homme est un animal inquiets et
insatisfait par nature alors afin
d'aborder ces questions j'ai très envie
de vous conter une histoire mais je vais
pas vous comptez n'importe quelle
histoire je veux compter mon histoire
est donc en fait moi j'ai toujours été
intéressé par la biologie marine j'ai
été passionné par la biologie marre et
j'ai rencontré le commandant cousteau
qui m'a dit voilà si tu veux faire la
biologie marine il faut embarqués sur
des bateaux océanographiques ce que j'ai
fait j'ai navigué sur la plupart des
océans est plongée dans les abysses avec
ses sous marins que vous voyez ici
le nautile alvin pour aller étudier des
animaux qui vivent dans des zones
extrême que l'on va trouver à 3000
mètres de fond dans les océans et puis
en 99
j'ai eu la chance d'être recrutés au
cnrs dont je suis passé j'ai passé
quinze ans au cnrs donc à roscoff en
bretagne
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir la médaille de
bronze du cnrs pour l'ensemble de mes
travaux
et ça m'a permis d'en fait d'assouvir ma
soif de connaissance et d'apporter de
nouveaux titres en fait à des chapitres
de sciences de la vie et j'ai appris en
fait sur mon chemin que finalement on
était capable en fait c'était possible
d'orienter son destin alors certes sur
ce chemin il peut se passer pas mal de
choses
et finalement on est capable de de
tracer sa route
et puis finalement de réaliser ses rêves
mais par contre on sait où on va tous
aller à la fin de ce chemin au
crépuscule de notre vie on ira tous là
désolé de casser l'ambiance a en fait la
vie c'est un chemin c'est un passage
entre l'alpha et l'oméga et que si vous
prenez conscience vraiment que la vie
est une succession de zones de confort
croyez moi vous n'aurez plus peur de
réaliser vos rêves
et donc moi il ya des animaux qui m'ont
extrêmement intéressé ce sont des
organismes que l'on va trouver sur la
plage alors je suis sûr que vous avez
tous vu ses traces en vous baladant sur
les plages en bretagne en dessous il ya
un verre que l'on appelle l'art et
nicole harry nicolas marina sever aussi
on l'appelle le bus du grand breton et
puis y en a qui l'utilisent pour la
pêche on en a discuté tout à l'heure je
me suis intéressé à cet animal pourquoi
pour essayer de comprendre comment ce
ver colonisent la zone de balancement
des marées chercheur au cnrs pourquoi ce
des marées et donc finalement ce ver il
est intéressant puisque ce ver il à 450
millions d'années
ça fait 450 millions d'années que ce ver
vie entre la marée haute et la marée
basse
juste à titre d'exemple l'homme notre
ancêtre australopithèques il a que trois
millions d'années
et alors moi je m'intéressais à cet
organisme pour essayer de comprendre
tout simplement j'étais au cnrs
comment ce ver respirer entre la marée
haute et la marée basse et donc pour ça
je me suis intéressé au centre cet
animal est en fait vous tous ici on a
tous du sang on a tous des globules
rouges et on a tous un typage sanguin en
fait le transport de l'oxygène se fait
par une protéine qui est à l'intérieur
de ce globules rouges qui va fixer
réversible le mans l'oxygène et
finalement en étudiant la respiration de
ce ver marin pour essayer de comprendre
comment ils respiraient entre la marée
haute et la marée basse
je suis tombé sur cette molécule alors
cette molécule a extrêmement
intéressante puisque ici on a trouvé
l'ancêtre de nos globules rouges en fait
à l'origine ce ver n'avait pas de
globules rouges en fait nous on n'avait
pas de globules rouges
et puis en fait on a évolué en fait une
molécule qui sait encapsulé au fur et à
mesure de l'évolution cette molécule est
extrêmement intéressante pourquoi parce
que voyez une molécule extracellulaire
qui peut lier 40 fois plus d'oxygène qui
peut être liée aux phillies et donc
aujourd'hui on peut avoir du sens en
poudre mais surtout qu'il n'ya pas de
typage sanguin est donc aujourd'hui en
fait qu'est-ce que j'ai fait quand j'ai
trouvé cette molécule la première des
choses que j'ai fait c'est je suis parti
en fait transfusé des animaux de
laboratoire
ah oui ça existe puis j'ai trouvé des là
j'ai trouvé en fait un laboratoire qui
m'a permis d'aider de tester l'hypothèse
en fait d'utiliser cette molécule comme
transporteurs d'oxygènes univers
elle gêne et des animaux de laboratoire
jean transfusés en fait cette molécule
est qu'elle soit perçue et vécue en fait
tous les animaux pouvaient vivre avec de
l'hémoglobine de vers marins et donc ça
ça a complètement modifié en fait ma vie
puisque fait je suis passé du cnrs à la
validation de cette de cette molécule
dans une entreprise
et finalement c'est ce travail ce
travail de recherche aurait pu en rester
là mais pourquoi parce que tout
simplement quand on est au cnrs
notre boulot c'est vraiment publier en
fait des articles scientifiques et ici
vous avez un exemple qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est le prix nobel albert
fert tki eu le prix nobel en 2007 pour
ses travaux sur la magnétorésistance
géante qu'est ce que c'est en fait c'est
le procès ce qui permet d'abord de
mettre des disques durs dans la plupart
des ordinateurs dans les mp3 dans les
iphone et vous avez peter greenberg qui
a eu aussi le prix nobel la même année
c'était un allemand et finalement albert
certes publié ses résultats
peter greenberg publiera également ses
résultats mais au préalable il protégea
ces résultats et donc aujourd'hui
peter gumbel à des royalties sur chaque
disque dur qui sont sur nos ordinateurs
et en plus il participe en fait au
développement économique de son pays
puisque finalement l'allemagne bénéficie
en fait de cette innovation majeure et
donc je décide de quitter le cnrs en
2007 pour créer en fait pour développer
cette cette molécule vers des
applications médicales et finalement je
deviens un peu le mouton noir de la
recherche parce que vous savez quand on
est au cnrs ont fait uniquement de la
recherche fondamentale et il est hors de
question que l'on aille valoriser en
fait les travaux de recherche puisque en
fait on a accès à l'industrie
et c'est très très négatif donc j'ai
troqué la blouse blanche contre un
costume je suis parti de l'autre côté en
fait de l'entrepreneuriat est
malheureusement en 2007 je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez 2007 c'était la crise
des subprimes et on me disait mais tu
vas pas quitter le cnrs puisqu'en fait
tuer fonctionnaires et ceux boîte mais
tu es fonctionnaires tu as un boulot à
vis tu vas pas prendre le risque de
créer son entreprise
eh bien je décide en fait de passer le
pas de créer mon entreprise est
finalement 2007 il y avait aussi une
élection présidentielle et il ya une loi
qui est passée par là qui s'appelle la
loi tepa la loi tepa permet à des
particuliers en fait d'un
investir directement dans le capital
d'une entreprise et et marina est la
première société en fait qui est sauvé
par cette loi passe lois fiscales et
donc en fait sur ce chemin j'ai appris
que finalement il ya souvent des signes
il ya souvent des signes il faut juste
savoir les regarder et la loi tepa en
était une mais il ya eu d'autres signes
sur le sur le chemin des marinas et
aujourd'hui maria c'est une société qui
croit d'une façon assez incroyable et
tout ça grâce à un petit ver marin qui
s'appelle l'art et nicole alors
aujourd'hui bien évidemment il était
pour moi hors de question de défaut
n'est toutes les plages de bretagne
d'aller piquer tous les verbes de la
plage pour en faire des produits
thérapeutiques donc aujourd'hui on a
ouvert des fermes des fermes
d'aquaculture une capable d'élever nos
verres marins dans les conditions
complètement tracé est contrôlée
d'extraire les modes et les molécules en
condition pharmaceutique et d'en faire
des produits thérapeutiques et
aujourd'hui et mme arena en train de
révolutionner des pans entiers de la
médecine
pourquoi parce qu'on a trouvé un
transporteurs d'oxygènes universel et
juste pour vous convaincre que cette
molécule a un intérêt majeur on va faire
un petit exercice essayez de d'arrêter
de respirer pendant une minute
non vous vous respirez la l'arête
exercice vous êtes convaincu en fait oui
parce qu'en fait la molécule là l
oxygène en fait c'est vraiment c'est
l'hémoglobine et l'oxygène c'est
vraiment au centre de la vie en fait
tous les processus métaboliques
physiologique ont besoin d'oxygène donc
on a créé cette ferme on a extrait nos
molécules et aujourd'hui avec cette
molécule on en fait un tas de choses on
développe cette molécule pour des
applications dans la transplantation
d'organes dans la transfusion sanguine
dans la cicatrisation pour les pour les
plaies du diabétique mais je vous
parlais plus particulièrement de cette
application dans le dans la
transplantation d'organes
quelques chiffres aujourd'hui la
transplantation d'organes c'est vraiment
un problème de santé publique majeur il
ya plus de 26000 personnes sur liste
d'attenté qui attendent un greffon et
sur cette liste d'attenté à peu près 500
personnes qui décèdent tous les ans
parce que aujourd'hui
imaginez-vous bien qu'on jette 50% des
greffons parce qu'on n'a pas le temps de
les transplanter l'idée que l'on a eue
c'était exactement de reproduire ce qui
se passait sur la plage
la question à laquelle j'ai répondu en
fait quand j'étais au cnrs et comment le
verts respirent entre la marée haute et
la marée basse va tout simplement le
vert ne respire plus à marée basse
ils fixent ces molécules d'oxygène en
fait sur cme globine et il reste pendant
six heures en complètement en fait sans
respirer l'idée c'était de reproduire
exactement ce qui se passait sur la
plage c'est ce qu'on appelle le
biomimétisme est en fait en mettant ces
molécules dans ses solutions de
préservation greffons on est capable de
multiplier par 4 ou 5 le temps de
conservation d'un coeur on est capable
de passer de 12 heures à une semaine
pour conserver un rein est aujourd'hui
les chirurgiens sont ravis puisque on va
pouvoir programmer et sauve et
programmer des transplantations
d'organes et surtout sauver ses organes
en fait de deux de remettre ses organes
en fait dans la liste d'attentes
alors bien évidemment une société comme
et marina c'est c'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille parce que vous avez bien
compris dans mon topo qu'il y a en fait
encore une certaine méfiance à valoriser
ces travaux de la recherche
comme si pour être un bon chercheur il
fallait complètement refusé obstinément
de discuter avec le monde de l'industrie
et pourtant c'est des grands
scientifiques d'un grand scientifique
tels que louis pasteur qui a dit il n'y
a pas d'un côté la recherche
fondamentale et de l'autre la recherche
et les applications de la recherche
appliquée il y à la recherche et les
applications de celle-ci unis l'une à
l'autre comme le fruit de l'arbre est
unie à la branche qui l'a porté lui
aussi avait bien compris comme léonard
de vinci qu'il fallait regarder vers la
nature pour trouver des innovations
majeures pour l'humanité merci de votre
attention
[Applaudissements]